chris bryant is joining us now um hello
to you mr brian thanks for joining us on
the program you're incensed
well i i'm not sure that incense is
quite the right word i'm appalled by
what chrisman has done i think um it's
particularly inappropriate on the day
when the home affairs committee has
produced a report on how terribly
difficult it is to get any rape
convictions um through the courts um and
so many victims not getting justice that
then a conservative mp when another
conservative mp is found guilty by a
court
by a jury in a in a court of law
and decides to um condemn the verdict
and condemn the whole process as i
understand it chrisman himself admits
that he wasn't there for the whole trial
he was only there for the defense he
didn't hear the prosecution he didn't
listen to the victim
and and the victims family so i just
think it's completely inappropriate um
quite a few crispin chairs one of the
um all party parliamentary groups which
i and others are members of which look
at lgbt issues around the world and
i think he will have to resign from that
i think he should have the whip
withdrawn and to be honest i think mr mr
khan should be stepping aside of course
he has a right to an appeal um and uh
we'll see how that goes but it's
completely inappropriate for a member of
parliament to start attacking the
judicial process like this
are you
saying are you asking christian blunt to
step aside and are you suggesting to the
government that they should remove the
whip which for the benefit of our
viewers means that he can't sit as a
conservative in the house of commons at
least tonight
i think crispin should have the wit
withdrawn from him yes because i think
this is a completely inappropriate um uh
way of proceeding we've seen this before
unfortunately if you remember that the
charlie elfic case the i mean a whole
series of conservative mbs even once
he'd been convicted decided to sort of
weigh in on his behalf um and that was
another sort of similar case um here
you've got a conservative mp who's been
found guilty last year we had owen
patterson who was found guilty by the
committee that i i chair of having
peddled influence for paying cons paying
clients around um parliament and the
government and the conservative party
through everything they had at trying to
defend their own i i just think it's a
completely inappropriate way of behaving
we quite rightly in the uk have a
separation um between the legislature
which writes the laws and the courts
which interprets the laws in specific
circumstances and
so i think crispin should have the whip
withdrawn um i think uh um mr khan
should be resigning his seat of course
he has a right to an appeal um uh it's
not for me to judge whether the court
case was right or wrong um a jury
listened to the evidence
a judge summed up and it came to a
conclusion
if we believe that the tweet from mr
blount has been uh deleted if you draw
um if he retracts the comment
is that a line drawn under the matter
and we can all move on
no i i don't think it is i'm afraid
of course you know it's it's great when
people apologize for somebody and say
i'm i'm really sorry i got this
completely wrong but i think the
conservative party needs to do a proper
investigation into um what on earth
crispin thought he was doing um you know
it is it undermines parliament it brings
parliament into distribute when a
lawmaker decides that um the
uh that a court of law has behaved
completely and appropriately in a
specific keys case when when even the
the appeal process hasn't been gone
through um all right so i i think as i
say um crispin first of all should stand
aside from chairing the all-party
parliamentary groups on lgbt issues
around the world and that's a shame in a
way because crispin has done lots of
really good work there and um but i
think he needs to step aside from that
we should be electing a new chair i
think um and the conservative party
should be investigating um why on earth
crispin came to this situation i don't
understand why and the conservative
party um you know wasn't straight out of
the door last night and first of all
saying that mr khan should step aside
from his seat and secondly that crispin
should be
withdrawing his comments immediately
although of course labour mp claudia
webb when she was
recently convicted in a court of law she
said that she would she was facing a
custodial sentence but said that she
would stay in place while she prepared
her appeal
yes i think that the same should apply
across the board to be honest and you
have a right to appeal of course and um
it's a great shame that some of these
appeals are taking much longer than they
should have done all of this in relation
in relation to claudia webb should have
been dealt with a long time ago um she
has a right to appeal mr khan has a
right to appeal um and no doubt they
will both exhaust that process um
personally i think that in an instance
such as that uh in an instance such as
both of these people should be stepping
aside
okay uh thank you for joining us chris
brown
you